what it sounds like is is like a lot of
excuses like covered excuses you know
things that things that you haven't ever
said before
no it's not unexcited as an excuse i
never said that no i didn't say you did
well then don't right it's
i mean look we paid cam million uh cam
newton a million dollars i mean it's
obvious we didn't have any money
you know
it's nobody's fault it's i mean that's
what we did the last five years we sold
out and
won three super bowls played in the
fourth and played in an afc championship
game you know this year we had
less to work with
it's not an excuse it's just the fact
all due respect everything that guy just
said is bullcrap
thank you
uh they didn't sell out they haven't
been dancing on the edge of the cap they
didn't mortgage the future that's never
been a narrative around the patriots hey
you know they're going to have a
reckoning one day hey they're like
that's what the cowboys do and you know
what in today's nfl chris with the cap
going up as it does every year now next
year is going to be different and
coincidentally or maybe ironically i
never quite know the patriots are in
great shape next year when the cap's
going to be 175 they've never been a
team that's in cap trouble that's
baloney they that what they did in past
years to win the super bowl was not all
calculated with the idea that you know
in 2020 were really going to suck
no i it was not you know they weren't
like in great cap shape all those years
they went closer and they still won yeah
but they went close to selling out they
did i mean they're paying 18 million
dollars right now to tom brady and
antonio brown and they're they're not on
the team i mean so
yes they did do a degree how long does
everybody think it can work and let's
like let's back off on the judgment i
mean yeah brady what would the what
would the results be like if belichick
got to go down and coach the tampa bay
team right now i don't know they'd be a
lot better too yeah brady's on a better
football team so so what does that mean
it proves oh it was brady no i know but
that's what they're getting at the
discussion it's so stupid that's all i'm
that's all i'm saying there i think this
team would be no better right now right
with tom brady at quarterback
it's just the point don't don't tell me
that you had some grand plan that 2020
was just not going to be a good year
don't tell me that i don't buy it i
don't buy it wait you're a victim of
your own success yeah yeah and i'll say
that you're right exactly i mean they're
a victim of their own success how long
could it last i mean you know they did
their best and do all those type of
things again it's still
turbo draft goats in a bad way we'll get
to that that's easy again
belichick is amazing let's see where
that goes
are people gonna say this if he builds a
new dynasty you know two years from now
and all of a sudden they're back like so
this story is not over yet and but my
point is he's making excuses that's an
excuse why not just say yeah we've
missed on some draft picks we haven't
made good decisions you know what we're
not you know we're not we've lost dante
garnekia don't just don't tell me it's a
cab situation because i think that's
crap
i don't know i don't know if that is
crap i don't i don't know if i agree
with you there too it's crap you know
again listen
tom brady's amazing goat whatever
everybody want to say you know will
never be the like the greatest
quarterback of all time in my eyes
some of these analytics firms go back
and look the advantages bill belichick
has afforded tom brady let alone the
talent he's had on the football team i
bet you if you go back and look through
brady's first 18 years of his career
it's the greatest pass protection of any
quarterback has ever had in the history
of football i bet you if they go back
and go separation between intended
target and guy defending he's thrown to
more open receivers than any quarterback
in the history of football i don't even
know this i just watch a lot of football
i'm gonna guess i'm right somebody pff
collinsworth call your guys start doing
it let's go i bet you that's the case
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports